عندما قام العالم الصيني هي جان كوي في
نهايه عام 2018
بتعديل جيني للاجنه البشريه كان يامل
الحصول على جائزه نوبل من خلال هذه
التجربه الواعده لكن بدلا من ذلك حكم عليه
بالسجن ثلاث سنوات فتجربته اثارت جدلا
كبيره في المجتمع العلمي باكمله كون هذه
التقنيه المستخدمه لم تكن ناضجه بما يكفي
لضمان سلامه الاطفال علماء وصفوا تجربه
بالوحشيه والمزعجه بشده رغم ذلك وبعد
خروجه من محبسه اعلن انه يخطط لتاسيس
عياده طبيه لاجراء بحوث لاستخدام التعديل
الوراثي فقضيه تحمل ابعادا اخلاقيه ولا
يزال يحذر خبراء من عدم تنظيم هذا المجال
خاصه في الصين حيث الضوابط الاخلاقيه
والدينيه يعتقد انها غائبه على كل حال
سنتعرف معكم اكثر عن احدث تقنيه في هذا
المجال والمخاوف منها نتابع
سنتابع معكم هذه التقنيه نظام كريسبر
للهندسه الجينيه بزغ نجمه بشكل واسع
وتقنيه كريسبيل للتعديل الجيني تتيح تعديل
الحمض النووي للكائن الحي وهي ثوره علميه
غير مسبوقه تتيح كريسبير للعلماء تعديل
الجينات من خلال مقص جيني يضاهي في عمله
برنامجا لمعالجه النصوص ويمكنها ايضا رصد
التشوهات الجينيه واستبدال عناصر اخرى في
الحمض النووي بها على كل حال كانت اول
تجربه ناجحه قد اجريت عام 2000 عندما تم
اصلاح النظام المناعي لمولود وقتها لكن
مجال التغيير الجيني زاخر بالمفاجات
المبهره خاصه ناحيه الطفرات فهناك تجارب
على ارانب معدله وراثيا لتكون اكثر نحافه
مثلا لكن اصبحت السنتها اطول من المعتاد
ومواشي تم تعديلها وراثيا لتكون بلا قرون
لكن النتيجه انه اصبح لدي حمض نووي بكتيري
ا يعزز مقاومه الجسم للمضادات الحيويه
[موسيقى]
على كل حال للحديث اكثر حول هذا الموضوع
معنا هنا في الاستوديو استاذ علم الجينات
والتطوير الدكتور عبد الله المطيري يسعد
صباحك دكتور عبد الله واهلا بك معنا في
صباح العربيه حقيقه موضوع الشائك موضوع
مهم وموضوع يهم كل الناس اليوم والبشريه
انا لما كنت عمالي بقرا كيف تحولت
الحيوانات بفعل التعديل الجيني خفت وقعدت
اتخيل ماذا يمكن ان يصبح لنا كبشر اذا ما
تم هناك الاخطاء مثلا لكن اولا خلينا نبسط
للمشاهدين ماذا يعني التعديل الوراثي
الجيني بابسط الكلمات تعديل وراثي هو بدا
مندل فلما اشتغل مع النباتات لكن هو معنى
انك انت يعني بالشيء الايجابي انه لما حد
يكون عنده مرض معين في جيم معين ممكن
تعديل هذا الجين الى الافضل في الفتره
الاخيره صار يعني لعب كثير
بالجينات فبالتالي في البدايه كان مجرد
تعديل جين واحد الان ممكن انت تصمم مخلوق
كامل او مولود كامل
الصفات اللي تبغاها على حسب الجينات اللي
انت تبغى يعني تدمجها مع بعض اوكي انطلاقا
من هذه النقطه اللي عم بتقولها يا دكتور
يعني يمكن السؤال اليوم ما هو الخط الفاصل
بان ان نقول الممارسه الطبيه غير
القانونيه غير الاخلاقيه لهذه المساله
وبين ان هذه التقنيه ستخدم البشريه وستحمي
البشريه من بعض الجينات التي تحمل مثلا
امراضا مستعصيه او حتى جينات خاطئه
والفائده ليست طبيه فقط انما اجتماعيه
وبيئيه وصحيه وايضا على مستوى الاطعمه
والاطعمه بالتغيير الوراثي لها لكن من
الفتره الاخيره في البدايه كانت التقنيه
الى حد ما صعب شويه يحتاج لها تجهيز خاص
لكن الفتره الاخيره جدا سهله فممكن اي
واحد عنده لاب صغير وعنده بعض المعلومات
بالبيولوجي ممكن يسوي التقنيه هذه في شروط
وضعوها او اخلاقيات وضعوها لعمل هذه
التجارب لكن في السابق كان في ريستركشن
عالي عليها الان لان كثره المراكز الابحاث
وكثره البحاث فصار اي انسان ممكن بادوات
بسيطه ومعلومات بسيطه ممكن يسويها في
البيت عنده يعني بيضه الدجاجه في البيت
وانت ممكن بعض الادوات تقدرين تسوين
تخلقين جيل معين او مخلوق معين طيب انا بس
بدي افهم ليش المخاطر وفي قلق وفي تحذيرات
من هذه التقنيه طالما انه قد يكون لها
فوائد وفوائد كبيره في المستقبل
الاستخدام فيها الغير غير منظم ممكن يعني
المخلوقات الموجوده ممكن تتحول الى
مخلوقات اخرى قد تكون ضاره قد تكون مفترسه
بالاضافه اللعب الانسان نفسه
لما نعرف الانسان ممكن تظهر صفات فيه غير
غير يعني غير محببه او غير مطلوبه لان
الان في الغرب في مراكز معينه ممكن انت
تروح
تعطي وصف كامل عن الطفل مالك كيف شكله من
لونه الى شكله الى طوله الى ذكائه الى كل
شيء فممكن حد يتجاوز بهذه يبحث عن صفات قد
تكون ضاره
وتنتشر بين المجتمع وفي نفس البشريه طماعه
يعني في حال اطيح اتيحت لها هكذا فرصه راح
تصير تفصل هالولد على قياساتها وهذا
بالنهايه عكس الطبيعه وعكس اراده ربنا
يعني حتى الجينات التي تغير لسبب معين
ممكن كلها تاثير اخر يعني ممكن يلعب اخر
فيؤدي الى مشاكل اخرى بصحه الانسان بشكل
عام طب اليوم ممكن نقول انه فوائد تقنيه
كرسبير تفوق المخاطر ان ضبط استخدامها
بالضبط لذلك الدول وضع التشريعات لكن في
الفتره الاخيره لانها سهل استخدامها فممكن
اي واحد يسويها من غير تشريع من غير
موافقه لكن اذا اتبعت الاخلاقيات في هذا
الموضوع حيكون يعني انجاز كبير للبشريه
لعلاج الامراض
ومعالجه مشاكل البيئه وما الى ذلك طيب عبد
الله مثلا انتم بالفتره الحاليه والمؤخرا
اذا ما حكينا على العقد الاخير يتم دراسه
الخريطه الجنيه مثلا للشخص لمعرفه الامراض
المتوارثه في سلاله هذه العائله في حال
مثلا جبنا طفل من عائله تحمل كثير من
الامراض وعدلوا هذا هذا الجنين وعدلوه
بجينات سليمه مثلا من الامراض هل هذا
سيعقد عملكم
كمختصين في علم الجينات لانه صار يصير
اصعب تعقب المرض الوراثي بعد تسلسل لانه
تغير من طفل جديد هو الطريق قبل الولاده
قبل بدايه الحمل يسوون طريقه
اللي هم قبل التخليقه الجنين وقبل النفخ
فيها الروح يقدرون يحددون شو الصفات اللي
قبل البرازيل يحملها هل هذا يعني هذا
الطفل عندما يكبر يتزوج سيحمل الصفات التي
تم تعديل وبه جينيا وراثيا حيكون انسان
طبيعي لانه هم اختاروا طبعا هذا يكون كومن
في
العوائل اللي عندها امراض وراثيه متكرره
فبالتالي لابد يخضعون لهذا النظام بحيث
انهم يضمنون الطفل
يعني خالي من الامراض الوراثيه
واكيد للحديث يتم في هذا الموضوع ولكن
انتهى الوقت شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عبد الله
استاذ علم الجينات والتطوير دكتور عبد
الله شكرا